en grupos más pequeños
polonia acusó a belarús de cambiar de
táctica de presión política enviando una
cantidad menor de migrantes y refugiados
a los diferentes puntos fronterizos con
la unión europea con el fin de presionar
al bloque por las sanciones impuestas
contra mainz algo que los mismos
migrantes denuncia para llegamos a
través de los bosques la seguridad de
lorenza intenta todos los días decir nos
vayan a polonia y no podemos cruzar así
que intentan hacernos cruzar a la fuerza
nos dejaron en vehículos militares los
guardias bien los rusos nos llevaron
durante tres horas no sabíamos a dónde
nos dirigíamos y no hay espacio para
sentar a mano y que
el mandatario bielorruso sigue negando
haber fomentado la crisis migratoria que
se prolonga desde hace más de dos
semanas la mayoría de personas llegaron
en avión hasta belarús procedentes del
medio oriente con la promesa de una vida
más digna en europa pero se encuentran
atrapados a lo largo de la frontera en
precarias condiciones tal y como
constataron los enviados de la
organización internacional para las
migraciones
hacemos un llamamiento a todos los
países para que cumplan las leyes
internacionales y los derechos de los
migrantes y refugiados y cooperen
inmediatamente para resolver estas
situaciones
en polonia cientos de personas salieron
a marchar por los derechos de los
solicitantes de asilo desde el pasado
agosto al menos 11 personas han muerto
la frontera entre ellos un menor a bing
bites están violando los derechos
humanos no deberíamos usar el
sufrimiento humano como herramienta
política y eso es exactamente lo que se
está haciendo en taxis exageres pintan
mientras tanto la unión europea se
blinda una vez más contra los migrantes
con estonia levantando una valla de
concertinas a lo largo de su frontera
con rusia